we're doing a lot of defending of the
First Amendment these days but this is
the latest official installment of our
series defending the first where we
expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free speech free thought and
tonight we talked to former Syracuse
professor Stuart Card who says he was
fired for defending free speech on
campus card says he was fired after he
privately disagreed with the school's
expulsion of students for their crude
skits at a fraternity roast let's find
out exactly what happened from the
professor himself Stuart card
welcome to the angle professor look my
producer watched the video the
fraternity video I guess was an internal
video it wasn't posted on social media
and it was gross to me that was I don't
know why people make these videos it was
gross and it's profane and so forth they
say it was a satire actually ridiculing
a conservative who apparently was you
know bad person even racist and so forth
you wrote a statement an email to the
administration and you said the
following I strongly believe that
reinforcing the current myth that
individuals are likely to be damaged by
exposure to expressions that they find
offensive and thus require pampering is
a disservice to our students in our
profession I know my view on this is out
of sync with current opinion but I was
toughened as a youth not just by
emotional billing bullying but by
physical beatings by much older and
larger students I survived I got
stronger I mean that's and then you're
separated from the University for that
well I have to say this isn't really
about Syracuse University I love
Syracuse University and the good people
there who are doing what they assume and
feel is right this is really about ideas
not specific institutions or individuals
it's about the ideas of free speech and
reason versus some dangerous irrational
myths that have swept the campuses
around the country I don't know whether
I was really fired or I quit we might
say that the University and I reached a
mutual agreement that the beliefs and
use of the university are no longer the
beliefs and valuation professor you
don't know if you that's cute you don't
know if you quit or you're you fired I
mean was there some type of lease they
made you sign do they delay no no they
didn't okay well he said when I sent
that email I concluded it with my if my
position on this is so objectionable as
to render me disqualified from further
service to our students then put me on a
list of don't use me as an adjective or
and the answer came back yes indeed your
values or not don't be obtuse you were
fired because you wrote that email
saying I'm concerned that we're coddling
students coddling them and trying to
protect them from all these offensive
ideas is not going to help anyone it's
not going to Vance the cause of learning
and that was the thing that they
ultimately said yeah you're right we
don't want someone like you at our
university you know and I know you're
protective of Syracuse that's nice but
the atmosphere on college campuses today
on a scale of one to ten one being the
most Pro free speech and ten being the
least Pro free speech where do you rate
it I'll give it an eight but I'm
shooting from the hip because I hadn't
thought about that number before another
one of these myths that I'm talking
about is this myth that's really
prevalent not just on the SU campus but
on other campuses that I've been to that
all educate intelligent good people
think pretty much the same on certain
key issues where the correct answer is
obvious and obviously that's omits that
another video tomorrow great point as
always